Greg Bryce tweets so a group of people
just randomly decided to ransack a Wawa
in Northeast Philly tonight check out
this video y'all all stupid
so like yo you're gonna give me my
sandwich she says are you guys making
food
eyes are all just basically ransacking
everything I don't know if I I think I
got photos of the aftermath
for the next article but first of all we
are all that girl if we're hungry we
want our stuff done hurry up hurry up
I'm hungry there you go look at this
it's getting crazy now look at this one
chick twerking she's she's twerking up
there it's usually just one she's just
twerking you know seeing that you're not
getting your sandwich all right you know
that I
only option you if you're really hangry
maybe they were hangry Maybe
here's the video of the aftermath the
whole place is just ransacked and not
only did they ran say that but outside
they're fighting each other yeah and
then jumping on jumping on cars and
destroying people's cars that were
parked in the park this is why we left
Philly America is safe guys American
cities are safe it's not called Philly
it's called Philadelphia all right now
you guys ready for the uh for the hammer
drop uh-huh okay you want to read that
one Luke Philadelphia mayor signs
executive order banning guns from city
parks that'll do it well there's rampant
murders happening in Philadelphia
because criminals who are committing
murder don't care about the gun laws and
people are just rampaging through these
stores
the the mayor's like I got an idea the
people who are obeying the law should be
restricted in from defending them from
defending themselves or stopping other
criminals from of course hurting them
with the firearms that they always
illegally carry since of course
criminals don't follow laws so anyway
anyway he's trying to make people feel
better in city parks okay
come on it's stopping it's like this
no no but it's like think about what
this policy actually means criminals are
murdering people they're breaking the
law they don't care about your laws so
the mayor goes and now law-abiding
citizens will have no right to defend
themselves it's like he saw the news and
then said I need to help these criminals
and that's the policy you get yeah
absolutely how else can you excuse it
other than innocent law-abiding citizens
will now be punished you don't
understand the city parks are safe now
the rest of the city maybe not now look
at this wait wait let me let me play the
sandwich thing I think she's I think
this is what she asked for the sandwich
y'all making food
what would you have me do we're being
raided every possession is being taken
away from us in this very moment and
she's like are y'all gonna record or
gonna make me some food no it's a it's a
shame that they don't have Publix in
Philadelphia because they make they make
the best sandwiches the best friendly oh
yeah it takes uh didn't they have like
horrible vax mandates and fire people
and discriminate against them no that
was Florida oh no no wasn't that public
no Publix uh the opposite or was there
another one no no no Publix there was a
a big hullabaloo with Publix because the
the Press was saying oh well the the
owner of Publix or some executive there
contributed to desantis's campaign and
then when when the vaccine was available
they said oh why don't we distribute the
vaccine at Publix and we're like oh no
they're they're getting like a
sweetheart deal it's like no because
it's just like a Publix everywhere yeah
and so it's easy if you want the vaccine
just find a Publix like they're
everywhere so it's a supermarket chain
right uh but the best Sanders it'll take
an hour to make a sandwich at Publix I'm
pretty sure that if this was in Florida
people would be getting shot
only in like what Miami right is Miami
Florida Florida's like really good on
gun rights and they're they're okay they
have a couple of red flags and you need
a permit to conceal carry all right
let's let's just be clear I don't see
any guns
not in Florida you can open carry in
Florida if you're going hunting yes no
I'm pretty sure you've got an idea to
buy a gun I don't know uh you could buy
a gun yeah but open carry uh is is
concealed carries allowed but not open
carry so you can conceal carry if just
if you get the permit no I don't know
yeah you could continue carry if you got
the permit yeah Florida's not the best
when it comes to guns rights yeah trust
me I had to go through a long
application and and like a whole test
they're trying to change it though right
like they can see just tried to push
constitutional carry but it didn't go
through in the local houses West
Virginia we don't get hurricanes and you
can carry guns with just an ID but is
there state income tax yes oh yeah so
but they're going to take Florida I like
Florida yeah Florida man just like
myself we love Florida Governor is
trying to get rid of it and it's the
legislature that won't that's blocking
him he's trying to eliminate the state
income tax West Virginia you know what
to do yeah eliminated and then for those
Western Maryland counties they're trying
to secede to join West Virginia so wow
there you go yeah I mean Philadelphia is
somewhere that I definitely don't think
anyone will want to move to I don't know
if you guys seen some of the videos that
people have been posting just walking
around Philadelphia showing the Havoc
showing the the drug abuse showing the
open-air drug dens that are in that city
axios is even reporting that uh that
that uh gun robberies have gone up 60
since last year uh robberies up 50
percent so it's just absolutely Bonkers
to see these latest crime stats and the
Mayors is focusing on on discriminating
against individuals for for trying to be
able to defend themselves in the Parks
which is absolutely freaking crazy it's
nuts but I wonder this crime is a big
deal and we just had the story where
Kareem Jean-Pierre who's just like
really bad at her job awful was asked
about crime and then they were like do
does Biden think cities are safe and she
was not a yes or no answer I mean it's
like just are you kidding man learn to
spin the answer is yes but I didn't
think the cities are safe because he's
been putting in a lot of work to reduce
crime and while we have seen a spike
they are starting to come down just spin
it spin it but she's just terrible at
her job but anyway well she did she did
two things she to to expand and she she
did say it's a yes or no question or
it's not a yes or no question but then
she keeps saying oh well with the
American Rescue plan we gave so much
money in funding to police officers and
firefighters and all these people to
help keep our city safe but she can't
answer whether the cities are actually
safe because of that funding it's
amazing so I mean she she's so awful at
her job and and everybody thought that
jensaki was like a smug
um you know what but at least she could
actually speak English and and not
but you know what the funny is awful the
funniest thing about jensaki is that the
way they have the camera on her you'd
assume she was like five eight and she's
like five one
yeah she's very very short and I don't
mean that in any way disrespectful I
just think it's interesting how the
camera angles will like Point upwards so
you assume she's This Tall Person well
she also wears like pretty big heels too
because when you see 15-inch platforms
when you see them walking into the it's
like when she goes when she used to go
like hi everybody and then she walks in
and says you know she's gonna Circle
back you know
you actually you know what's funny about
that just just as a side note I did a
video pointing out that she would say
I'm in a circle back like you know a
whole bunch of times then she stopped
saying it no I think because because of
you I think because people are like yeah
you're really getting hit hard on this
circle back thing you've got to stop
using that phrase I think what happened
was that she is a big fan of yours
she watched your video and she was she
was hurt and she like cried a little bit
because she's like my favorite show and
he's making fun of me uh oh sure
sure I'm sure that uh I'm I would I
would have to say that I I I think that
AOC and her staff knew who I was because
I was a very early adopter on YouTube
like there were nobody was doing videos
on ASC before I did and uh and I went
like on an off day to Washington and I
went to her office and the office was
locked like everybody's closed and I
just you know took some pictures in
front of uh the little plaque and I saw
her old Chief of Staff uh shy cot yeah
shocker Barney he was he was walking
down the hallway and he he kind of shot
me a look like so they knew they knew
who I was they were like sitting on
YouTube and there's like grumbling
they're like oh man she like griffed her
well well none that well definitely not
a grifter come on you know I believe I
actually believe what I have to say
other than you know
on traveling I'm sorry
um you okay though yeah I'm fine thank
you yeah so uh but yeah I think I think
a lot of people
um do you think a lot of people in
Washington watch
your show yes
that's it expand that's it yes no okay
okay well you we we get requests a lot
we get tons of PR companies hitting us
up about politicians and I just kind of
like
yeah politicians man like when you know
when you guys have Marjorie Taylor green
on like she's she's great she is she's
great she and she's smart and and she's
I I hate how the media tries to paint
her as like this dumb broad she's she's
smart and she's genuine and I really
like her and I just want to give a shout
out to you
um Congress congresswoman and and
Marjorie people like Marjorie Taylor
green and Carrie like by all means
disagree with their politics they'll
come in here for three hours and talk
about whatever you ask them and and I
like we can ask pretty absurd questions
yeah DMT graphene you name it we got
into it and the graphing must have been
you right yeah
intelligence agencies and Epstein we
talked about it all which is awesome I
say bring the nastiest serious
politician in here sit him down right
here let's have a good conversation yeah
but the problem is
there have been some politicians we've
had on and it's just like not good right
because you'll be like what do you
because they'll because they'll go full
politician you'll be like do you think
that you know we should have guns blah
blah and they'll go well I think it's an
interesting question you know the issue
is and you're like yeah
you know but it was funny when I think I
think Kerry Lake we asked her about
nuclear weapons and she was I was like
should you think people should have a
right to have I think it was care like
I'm not sure because I'm like do think
two-way protects your right to have
nuclear weapons and like they have no
problem like no and then I'm like okay
well I think it does and it's just like
you have a real conversation and I'm not
saying people should have nuclear
weapons but if people could have you
know privateers with like a wall of
cannons yeah why would they now all of a
sudden but more importantly it literally
does case in point private companies can
apply for nuclear weapons if you have
what is it class was it level three FFL
or whatever what does it look I I'm not
sure to be honest with you there's like
certain levels of federal firearms
licensing you can get and you can get an
application for a nuclear weapon because
private companies make these things you
gotta lie for it so it does protect your
right to have them and the US government
is incompetent and has lost a number of
nuclear weapons a lot of people don't
even know this but yeah why should we
trust the government with it when they
can't even uh hold them legitimately and
they lost them on record which is
absolutely crazy so which corporations
have nuclear weapons any anybody want to
pontificate probably Northrop Grumman
Halliburton Boeing Lockheed Martin
Raytheon Oh I thought you were talking
like you know McDonald's Macy's
you better you better raise our stock
otherwise we'll unleash and now and now
that serious is you know it's like
almost gone you know all their nuclear
weapons are on the black market yeah no
they're just like rotting and silos
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there